back soon with more on that aging cream
but what we have right now is very
exciting it's an incredible laptop deal
Microsoft and HP have teamed up to bring
you the $200 HP stream 11 that's just
two hundred dollars no special deal or
layaway plan for a real laptop running
the full version of Windows 8.1 and
there's more it also includes one
terabyte of Microsoft cloud storage
space this is a crazy deal okay no I'm
not really a home shopping host but this
does seem like one of those unbelievable
have seen on TV deals for years I
reviewed ultra cheap Windows netbooks
but those were toys compared to the
stream which was built to destroy the
Google Chromebook that's why I put the
stream up against a sirs $200 Chromebook
11 they both have similar specs and 11.6
inch 1366 by 768 display an Intel
Celeron processor and two gigabytes of
RAM the stream may be thicker and
heavier than the Acer but the build of
the system is nicer the keyboard is
comfortable and doesn't cave when I type
and the trackpad is surprisingly usable
now if I was actually a home shopping
host this is where I'd lied to you and
tell you the colorful design of this
laptop is just so fun and so hip but
that's not true unless you're into polka
dots all over your keyboard frame but
you may forgive the childlike design
when you hear that the battery lasted
seven hours now we've got mark on the
line from Maine mark what made you
purchase the HP stream today hey Joanna
good to be on well I've been wanting to
work on my PowerPoint slides without an
internet connection mark that's a great
point
unlike Chrome OS you get the full power
of Windows and Microsoft Office whether
or not you have a Wi-Fi connection it
also means being able to run any Windows
programs you want thanks for calling in
plus Microsoft even throws in a year
subscription to Word Excel and the
others with
365 that in itself is $70 think about it
that way and this laptop cost just a
hundred and thirty dollars but not so
fast
literally the Acer was much peppier in
fact the stream can be frustratingly
slow Microsoft Word and other apps ran
fine but Internet Explorer buckled under
the pressure of seven or more tabs go
for a $500 laptop with an i3 or i5
processor and you'll avoid this just
wake me when you decide to load in case
you're just tuning in the HP stream 11
is quite a deal though not what I'd call
a Chromebook killer if you want a $200
computer to solely surf the web the Acer
is a better performer but if you want a
$200 computer to do more than that
especially when you're offline and it
also to have the full power of office
then there's now a modern-day netbook
for you coming up after this
a great deal on a mouse made out of
tanzanite